yeah welcome to this video round seven
coverage of the supreme masters 2013 or
simply the Norway 2013 super tournament
aside started to call this tournament
the first couple of videos and I'll stay
with that now yay around 7,000 is some
the 12 to watch as the the posture of
kayaking who still eats the tournament
but don't yeah let's see what what
happened today yesterday I am as so
often start the video by announcing that
wouldn't be so long as usual and at the
end I failed miserably as usual I got 17
minute video again this time I promise
that will be shorter simply because it's
so late already here that I am simply
click I'll do such a long video again
let them get hurt him we have sweet long
against topple off as the first game and
this I must say is pretty much the
dallas game that i watched all year it's
probably something around that we see
this villa repeats the opening that
calls the plate against me with short
castles in that game there they played
this a 6 we should be three lined funny
but dumb to pile of no plate 96 d4 we
have some traits and yeah some traits is
the story of this game which was
exchanged on d7 done after some further
developing moves wise decided to play
five yeah this basically yeah entered
the game for today if you look at this
now there are their mass exchanges maybe
a suitable so considerate that that the
opening was some yeah basically um yeah
not too successful for him and that he
is no chance to
for any kind of edge in other ways so
this is a trade-off lots of pieces and
we see further exchanges yeah black now
I'm of course if you get this in I can't
take on c2 because you've got this
coming and this gets very annoying or
route c7 that's probably better even
cannot take you so wish it takes and we
see even more stuff exchanged yeah i
played through this sir a place for this
really quickly simply because there's
nothing happening like it's just in time
to to do the proper exchanges here
taking on f7 leads to nothing because
after this the night needs to move and
there's also this pawn or not a one
alright i can just can i if you are they
and this is may be tricky I don't know
that I see can still lose a completely
dull position but black can attack the
night first and and activate the king
yeah this is probably better it's still
it's still upon and if you try something
like this the active King is excellent
okay but done in the game he just played
a three and we got to King and porn and
game even and this is also dead just
complete draw yeah a5 is a funny move
but it just secures that everything is
closed the Queen side is closed and
there's also fortress type position on
the Kings side ya see that all possible
squares are controlled now for whites
king and in case of each form blood pres
each five blocks it yet now black only
needs to stay within this area and to
watch the beep on the kind of position
where you
really can grab any I don't know
three-year-old and tell him briefly yeah
you put this there then you draw against
the sixth time Russian champion okay so
very very dull game let's not waste any
more time with that and the switch to
borrow against our own IAM which was
slightly more exciting but not much to
be honest we had done a flag opening
with Knight f3 g3 reti opening this is
quite similar to what I blame myself
sometimes is right um d3d 3 was played
in fact in this position when when I
white here I immediately exchange it on
d5 and then played III something like
that this is what would i play because i
don't like what happened in the game
aronia now captured on c4 which is not
particularly great for black but it's
it's really dull got the d file open now
and yeah this is an interesting try for
one how do you get the D file open now
and black and easily play c6 and e5
sometimes or just c6 and stay white has
the hard time to make any progress own
right age for is in fact interesting
because it plans this attack on the
bishop and this is was a nice some
counter maneuver attacking the knight
black didn't want to obviously drop this
bag and allow why to take so the Dwight
them at least it's got the two bishops
but also that position shouldn't be
anything i'm grateful wide this is even
better probably attacking the knight
just drop back
and Bishop 360 you preserved your bishop
and blank even place with f6 to make
sure to keep this piece off to learn
yeah get a good foothold in the sand i
can drop here if you want but you can
also prepare a 5 and legs got a good
night on c5 this is also not doing so
much in fact if you look at this they
exchanged a couple of pieces here and
yeah around here action my suspicion is
that mainly one how had some something
somewhere those pieces here are simply
better than blacks pieces so it wouldn't
be a surprise if there is something but
I didn't see anything so substantial
Aronian just decided to give up the
bishops but this is still a very solid
position consider this 25 and after that
this the night gets a nice post 26 where
do some hard to to dislodge it's just a
good good position down and you also
also have this Bishop activation so very
difficult to imagine how wide would make
any big headway here in the game ironia
played this night f4 idea and after this
yeah found the precise move to just
cover the pawn but after this we had
repetition now with with this yeah yeah
I could white play on him what about
rook to d6 yeah the problem is this is a
really very weak black hmmm that very
good counter play with rookie 32 to
attack that wider tries to
yeah this even know something like this
possible mate okay this is not forced
white doesn't need to be a animating net
but can easily imagine black being a
better if you're not careful there are
so many pawns on light squares it's a
structure point a few black is very much
ok ok so it was the draw with this group
age sex h6 h7 repetition ok in the next
game is a job off against are not and
yet realized i was a bit I've been
shocked by this game it's it's quite
apparent that if you look at the
candidates tournament starting from the
candidates in in mid-march to the
beginning of April and until now her job
office in pretty terrible shape I mean
lots like 50 rating points and the
process and he's about to lose even more
in this currently running tournament
yeah he is playing against Anand who's
also maybe not in super ultra great
shape but I just have a look at this
game we get a Catalan opening with c5
and now it is pretty much clear that the
only way forward for y deserve is
castles and after 96 wide um can choose
between various moves if you want to
play it safe you can always just take
here and try to pay for a very small
edge on the true job of played in a
different manner he played Queenie
forecheck try to get the porn back
immediately to me it to be honest it
looks like I'm yeah like the attempt of
a person who wants to really get the
simplified easy game and not solve any
difficult problems or try to what you
trying to do something active we should
be seven less logical Queen takes and
Bishop to c6 I think very nice setup for
black now if you look at this castles
97-93 Andrew c8 so black has got a very
harmonious position especially important
in the same regardless the bishop on c6
the usual problem for black and the
Catalan is the bad bishop on c8 opposed
to White's great push up on g2 and here
black easily got in night this herb shop
d7 to c6 putting it on the long diagonal
without any young other problem that
black might have adjust the good bishop
that is an even counterpart to the g2
bishop yep like some hero doesn't have
any any problems but now we see that the
first couple of strange moves on I mean
paper a job if you can't Bishop e3 and
I'm not sure that this is a great idea
black and ours got in b5 with the tempo
and this some already wins some time for
black the problem is if white takes with
this there's nine to be six attacking
the Queen and yeah where do we let you
go now go here let's see form and bitter
strapped or trapped is the wrong road
the queen is attacked at them it's a
double the tank actually like winning a
piece yeah this is the same cannot take
so the Queen needs to move again and now
i'm on diseases the chance before
attacking the night and the night
doesn't have a good square it just needs
to return and this is followed by sea
form so black one lots of tempe b5 b4 c4
all with
with the tempo and in the meantime has
expanded nicely on the queenside you can
now evening is aaliyah majan that those
two pawns again the beach upon ya will
form a passport in the in the near
future and what what was why doing in
the meantime Knight to c3 and and all
the way back so it's a really bad
opening result for a Java phone so it's
hard to understand what what is doing
for us he really is out of shape for
whatever reason I know no idea or inside
information what's going on there what
history is playing in a strange strange
manner yeah here it's just a question
and how big black etch already is here
are not could have played in various
ways he could also have played just a
five protecting the porn on before but
this is what he played is also fine I
would be probably a bit reluctant to
play that because it feels like this
night gets a good square again but this
is not really a problem we see in the
game that blacks got two nights can
challenge a knight on c3 and is even
night a fourth sometimes attacking be
too so this is a fine set up yeah white
with 95 tried for more exchanges which
was a successful operation you've
exchanged more pieces but the pressure
is still there legs got this potential
two against one porn just need to remove
the c3 bishop which is easily possible
and it's not clear what what White's
plan is theoretically something in the
center because you've got to set the
bones against one but it's very far
to see that anything's happening there
f5 is a good news it prevents in
foursome play white theoretically can
play your form but I have a look where's
this piece now going how do i can't
really and now like to take and it's a
problem now if you drop it back this
ideas add some it's really am a
problematic position this f5 movers
secures squares in the center like II
form and indirectly d5 of course it
looks like weakness but there's always
bishop f 66 takes only five to get rid
of this single piece that can beat the
annoyance so I fibers are pretty typical
move in this kind of position every you
should g5 and drop in back here now y
term it's in the real dilemma here like
it's just threatening to take it with a
gap almost winning end game just imagine
why this doing in nothing move like this
what are you doing against this caption
with them a big pass bone from black can
go here but c3 you know something like
this gets punished very hard and black
wins so in the game he played a form
trying to get some sort of counter play
in the center but Alan could simply take
it off take a form and then enter with
the Queen yeah and this is just simple
and very strong still f3 hands
combined with the FA drug and laga
threatening to take CC 3 to establish a
monster porn and b3 only moves as a tag
of the Queen at 25 yards and it's a nice
position and through your threatened and
you've got this idea Queenie one and
rope the eight and the update is one of
those yeah not too spectacular but
strong moves and not so easy actually
and so the the thing is you look at this
it looks like black has a useful
position of Queen and roca against their
free porn and the white seems somehow
tied up a bit too to this certain spawn
so you maybe don't consider to move the
rook away from f8 but in fact this is a
good idea what the black is trying to do
is to to get entry squares on d two or
possibly on on v3 at some other stage so
you use the rook on the open file
actually not on the semi open file and
after this son it's basically wide
breaking down Brooksie one and now
strong move again Queen to be five and
this makes yeah this clears the way for
the rook to enter on d3 you add a text
c3 and III ads it's very hard to
tolerate such a look like and even then
double on the default and why does
pretty much same way that it's very hard
for him to to make any of any meaningful
moves the group d one would be three
there we go took it again now black
threatening to just grab c3 it's out
move the neither the bishop away
and black gown wonder spawn after d2 is
quite cred fleshy final move on a job of
resigned it Sam enough he actually how
on earth do to make it at night here I
have automatic promotion setup yes even
his ambassador to promote you annoyed
with check um yeah after due to our job
of resigned there's simply simply no
move something like this can also just
be answered with this and it's not even
possible for why do two sec the bishop
against the poem this is just promoting
completely so really a terrible game I
am a job of what else can you say if
some for some reason just not the player
that he usually is it started in the
candidates and somewhat continues in the
tournament so afterwards okay so now we
get to the games of the two tournament
leaders coyoacán I have a point and add
off on Gaza let's do Magnus games the
game first just second-tier okay here we
go this is jean-luc de comer against
causal so causal plays them against his
old schoolmate actually I think they
really young knew each other from from
when they were really little so I also
remember that in the early days of
Magnus playing on the ICC um I actually
played him when he was about ten years
old I was funny you know he had this in
the finger notes hello I'm make a
scholar from Norway ten years old and of
course back then
even beat me and of course you always
thought okay this is just some fun jokes
instead of being going to be in 10 year
old kid of course now we know it was a
ten-year-old kid and back then about
around this time when he was like 10 or
11 years old he sometimes had the
sentence and the finger notes I am
better than John lat week so they were
there were just just the fun's just a
fun sentence with smileys and so on like
there was some childhood drywall's okay
it's just a fun fact for this game so we
have the catalan he as well and cause it
takes and now place this check yeah
there are many ways to combat the
catalan this is one of them connected
with the move a five quincy to try to
get the Pont back of course and now
Carla took on the d2 yeah this isn't
hacked a very concrete line the sum this
whole think that black is playing him if
why they are we captured with the night
which is by far the most natural move
black can in fact play b5 and try to to
keep his his pawn the point is compared
to some other lines with b5 that after
night move like 95 in the long run
there's even a rock move to secure the
work yet probably 95 should be played
for us but important is that this route
can can get out of the dangle our song
this is a playable for white sand no
question one possible ways to play a for
c6 and b3 and make a complete gambit out
of this something like this offers wide
very nice compensation in form of the
week dark squares
yeah lots of players want to avoid this
v5 scenario and play Queen txt to this
is also what hammer played here and this
has a fun idea if black now place b5
there's the cute poof Queen g5 attacking
two pawns very weird form of a double
attack and in fact black can play
castles and sacrifice this special
basics I'm sure yeah this is of what I'm
what I want to say is this is a valid
way to play for for both sides and it's
considered to be M about equal in the
game or ever cuddle played just see six
probably trying to prepare b5 soham I
went a form and now night to e4 yeah
this is an interesting news I was a bit
surprised by this I think this year only
has got the idea to get rid of one pair
of minor pieces when white needs to
spend two moves to to get the porn back
like make sure that one night is
exchanged we see that this happened and
now this night is got a nice a post on
before the at first you think okay maybe
why this better look at this bishop on
c8 it's not great but one thing that
black can always do when in fact he did
so here you can play b6 and Bishop a six
and at the end there is the idea c6 to
c5 and blend if black managed to get the
edit button it will be you be to gridley
equal probably and then the game in fact
we have some some more exchanges coming
ya see hive-like opens up the center but
now we get some trades yeah there's not
so much happening actually um let me
switch to my notes okay we should have
one group to c8 yeah here's a critical
critical point of the game and I think
it in this position um how much maybe
could have firm wrapped up the game to a
draw but maybe now that I look at the
clock times I only did this now causal
really was down on time surprisingly he
rarely gets in the one time but here it
seems he did okay what I'm trying to get
it is that Knight to f5 now would be a
very good try to simplify the the game
down to a draw black gum needs to do
something here goin subject g7 this is
not on at least a five words lot more
let's just one move night oops night
back to f6 and after this white can um
just take him after who takes there's
something like this happening with
Meredith yeah further exchanges and in
the complete complete draw like this
black and take with the pawn this is a
bit more bit of a fighting alternative
but rooty six is a good reply what's
black supposed to do can take on and
take on e to you want can can try that I
don't look at this those pawns are still
weak and wide we'll win some of it back
and then we change the venta minor piece
it's not too attractive not at five is
some I guess move that probably should
secure the draw but okay look at the
clock times Carlton was really down on
time and I BF me i don't know maybe it
was just derivative deliberately tried
to get in time travel to attempt the
white clear to try something but this
could be it could be far-fetched really
the stuff like that rarely happens yeah
what the Jelavic did he played them lie
to be five and this term i dont that
dont really don't really get like talk
and nine f6 and now you're always in
danger to get into a worse end game
simply because of the porn weaknesses
here and get black has called a night
against the bishop and potentially the
night is a much better piece in this um
symmetrical structure in terms of
majority symmetrical structure this is
what was played now kini aid in fact i
think that exchanging is slightly more
precise but um it could be wrong of
course this just looks like a good line
to me white can can play you for here or
i could have played before that this
would have happened but something like
this
feels like a very good position for
black I think this is actually what
karma served on a plate King to aid and
I understand now because of the time
travel probably he didn't he wasn't able
to do to judge this properly now white
played the Queen to d3 and this is it
seems I'm a mistake the more active move
Bishop to g2 was better this is just
threatening Bishop c6 winning and it's
not so clear what black should do one
thing and I must show us that this in
fact can be answered by King edge to
this looks at me this looks incredibly
stupid but what is plaque going to do
now at the end of all this they're still
be six hang and if this falls the b-form
supported by the bishop will be very
strong I'm not sure how black is going
to try to to play for when here can
easily add backfire if you're not too
not cautious I wish up GT what G to now
was there was a stronger move but he
played Queen to d3 and now this is very
typical even with not much on the clock
it's a sort of a technical position and
now Magnus plays very very strong move
simple but strong 25 this seller gets
the Queen's off no way to avoid the
trade now why it took and now we even
took with the poem this is Sir this is
also strong decision not with with the
night the knight on d5 doesn't have a
good it doesn't have good stability can
always be kicked by e for some moves or
Bishop g2 and this is just just very
strong now black controls the only open
file it's just that sample and b5 and be
to our weaknesses there's even this idea
after possible look trade
black attacks b5 with the king very
critical now for White he went before
probably trying to complicate matters
and retained black but it really didn't
work out played the Roxy to just
ignoring this I think was a bit more on
time on the clock he would have taken
him because there simply is no no big
play for white he was really a bit of a
bluffing a bluffing roof this is
possible and needs to be checked but it
is not dangerous something like this
yeah this is a possible line materially
quality but the position is terrible b2
gets lost and this is rewritten and
maybe night to d3 threatened why does in
big trouble this should should lose
really yeah well it didn't happen we had
rube see to d5 and after if I have it's
lost him but this this is what wider
could have and probably should have done
rook takes and now d 6 this is some
counter play also based on the idea
Bishop to a ch3 group c 1 root c8 mate
this is a possible how to play for right
now but it seems that them not too
obvious and slightly computer assure you
from age 5 as an idea or a force an idea
both seems to be good to computer
profess h5 but a for looks more natural
to me I think black ass is better here
it's not super clear cut if it is an
easy win but likes the one calling the
shots of course with this activity and
the passport yeah in the game he played
the e5 here
this didn't really help I cannot
exchange rules drop back and now the
April yeah yeah black needs to stand
this couple of checks but it's not
particularly threatening and after we
have King text if I yet BB camera
resigned he there's simply nothing to do
if you take him then the importance is
actually promoting already we have a
somewhat funny case where this Bishop
which is usually the the biggest best
greatest piece in the Catalan is in some
small way dominated by the night um yeah
a winform Carlton again he's now scored
his third consecutive win including the
one against his main rival in this
tournament kayaking he also beat hammer
here today and is still in the hunt no
matter what your job or fun know what
kayaking plays in this game ok so the
kayaking game let's have a look at this
and he's playing a camera so Nakamura
yeah it's got the chance no with a
witness black he would be on an even
score with kayaking okay here we go so
we've got a Sicilian night off with
Bishop g5 some kayaking goes further the
sharpest a move that can easily lead to
very complicated battle but it's also
move there White has many options to to
play for four straws if it suits them
I'm Nakamura place night be 27 this is a
slightly yeah it's a line let's let's
start the sentence some other way it's a
line that is it's currently
a fashionable line but it was for a very
long time considered to be very risky
because black delazes king site
development but it's it's playable
player of course queen to e to this is
some getting a more popular in recent
times it was also the reply of who you
find who played against them on mountain
in vacanza early this year Queenie 21 of
course prepares long castles and wants
to support this quick push in the center
g6 this is uncommon normally black
switches back to ideas with with e six
or even be 5 g six is somewhat to
somebody curious a form this is all
standard looking silly and stuff but I
think it's a very uncommon or even new
position um here ki can plate the for me
somewhat surprising move g3 and wouldn't
have really thought about developing the
bishop here of course it sensible you
develop this piece and so on I probably
am was more inclined to play something
aggressive like that I don't know maybe
this is how i can where I would've
played if he had me if he had white
don't know okay but g3 is not a bad move
at all it's just a bit slow h6 and yeah
not much else need to take you should be
too white is so nicely developed yeah
the exchange and now castles yeah if you
ask me I like white in this position um
somehow this this doesn't feel feel
right to me this weekend King side
and quick call advances while blacks
counterplay is not that obvious to me
and it's probably a matter of taste
somewhat of course i would i would
prefer to be YTM it probably a matter of
taste yeah it looks a bit silly to walk
into this but black couldn't retreat the
other way because of a five something
like this is just resigns this is what
why you went to see seven and now if
I've you can just take or play 60 so
edge form and white has the simple
attacking idea which seems tricky to me
already I don't know I don't like black
here but this um maybe I'm as managing
the matter of tasters the computer
thinks black is perfectly alright but I
still don't like it okay rook c8 and age
56 cm in this position on the computer
prefers prefers a light to e3 avoiding
the doubling of pawns on c3 and it seems
like an okay move but i don't think that
kayak and smooth was suppose any any
worse just drop back to see three yep
like to quickly the problem is yeah
you've you follow for full of holes yeah
this is a weakness the kingside is weak
and alone the computer i am um plays
differently it wants to play something
like like this for example but isn't
this good for white
yeah it is better you maybe you can you
can try that but it's uh it's very very
shaky yeah this is possible and if
anybody yeah white is better when I
camera I took Amy in fact what he did it
wasn't so terrible it's just when i say
i don't like the position this is much
of personal preference as well queen of
six takes digs takes and at first you
think await this is an important point
right Dwight winning I know it's not
it's not a win yet here black for
example on had a very important the
chance ET he could have taken on c3 with
rook and in fact it's not only could
have he really should have because he'll
taunted really was too too bad but this
is nice its lair it's still a playable
position the critical move is I think
the tactical v5 p.m. for example rook
takes Queen takes the queen of f6 night
takes and group takes c6 white is better
here but black ass got counter chances
on g3 and the slightly weakened kingside
formation um this is probably what
should have been tried and black still
has chances to to hold this in the game
nighty five was played and this is a
really a brother big mistake in fact
them kayaking here could have one
instantly with the move Queen to d1 he
had played some other Queen retreat but
Queen d1 is very strong the ideas after
night c4d five
cui 72 just returned back to g4 and dumb
nothing that can be done like it's just
the bastard here can take here but after
this like I never take this is a maid so
after the capture on d6 here like
actually needed to to let this pontiff
this is some also toast 21 was somewhat
stronger but not but kayaking played
queen to h1 it's not bad as well this is
saying this is the same and well the
general kind of position is simply a
welcome simply bad for black keen-eyed
moved and then he five this is strong
and rook default back this is now a
matter of technical play in some in some
way and kayaking first centralizes and
doubles on the default so that will be
seven as a possibility yeah can tagged
one can sacrifice the PCM threatening
this in the process black took and now
work on the 710 I we see that the Queen
move by black for example here is
punished with Queen to be seven and this
mating pattern is deadly this is of
course does it help yeah so what should
nakamura do we gave up the queen
and now I I can open up the position
yeah it took a while maybe you had some
more frosting way but it is it is just a
win you want you can do get this a bit
more deeply but there's really not much
to comment on why dumb wonder the Queen
for the two pieces and picked up a lots
of cause this is your store yeah the the
result of all this basically yeah I
didn't know that they played so many
moves okay okay wow I can where I really
played on for a long time okay here okay
again with everything else fails you can
still just take the phone and and win
this win this position so I'm another
win for kayaking whom looked a bit shaky
with the lost to two cars but its back
on track here winning an important game
against Nakamura it was a very
complicated unclear position in fact i
was admitted just late at the moment for
me to to do a a look or more detailed
analysis of this kind of position around
around here moved 12 to 2 15 16 say
where was some telling that i thought
that white is better but ok maybe some
deeper analysis would help to convince
me otherwise I thought the blackest and
slider trouble even here already
all right the five games for today and
it means that kayaking and cousin are
now the only two players realistically
can win this cousin on plus 3 kayaking
on plus 4 so I think in the next arrival
is on +1 probably island after the win
today so one of those two young guys
from 1990 they are both from 1990
kayaking and cousins so 23 years old or
maybe 22 I'm not sure about the exact
birthdays um yeah they will be the ones
to decide the tournament on yeah thanks
for watching and this time it was
somewhat quicker video